On May 12, 2588, the entity known as SCP-UBU
manifested in Kangaatsiaq, Greenland, like
something out of the most nightmarish Kaiju
movie never made.
Soon after, there was no more death, but the
world was filled with such chaos and despair
that humanity longed for that eternal release.
From its enormous stomping feet to its cloaca,
to its face, featureless save for a gaping,
grinning, devouring mouth, the entity was
pure malice with all the time in the world.
UBU decimated the planet, breaking the spirit
of mankind and razing every city to the ground.
In the earlier days of UBU's invasion, when
there was still dry land, and people still
wanted to talk to each other rather than joining
floating islands of eternal, chemically-induced
slumber, they would commiserate about the
shared misery of the state of things.
"Oh, UBU?
My daughter hasn't spoken to me ever since
that monster shoved my whole body down her
throat…"
Someone would say.
Another would pipe up, trying to one-up the
first man in a sort of trauma Olympics: "Didn't
you see me in the news?
UBU carried me around for a week, snacking
on me every now and then — like I was his
personal turkey leg.
It was hell — but honestly?
Part of me felt a little bummed out when he
threw me away…"
Yet another person would chime in, like veterans
swapping war stories over a drink at the bar,
"UBU made me eat a pair of my pants, whole
thing, zipper and all.
Then he decided he thought that was funny,
made me eat pair after pair after pair of
'em, rinse, repeat.
By the time he got bored, I had eaten probably
around 20 pairs, sort of got a taste for them
after that…"
Everyone on the planet had good reason to
despise SCP-UBU, but no one held more hate
in his heart for the pale, wicked creature
than Dr. Laurence Michaud.
Before the world was turned upside down (sometimes
literally), Dr. Michaud was a member of the
mysterious O5 council at the SCP Foundation.
To be specific, he was O5-11.
But that prestigious position at the Foundation
couldn't protect him or his loved ones from
the wrath of UBU.
When Dr. Michaud was off duty, UBU attacked
him and his wife.
First, it impaled his wife on a broom handle.
Next, it threw Dr. Michaud into an open pool
of sewage in the street.
Then, it bathed him in the filthy water, using
his screaming wife as a scrubbing brush, all
the while whistling a horrible little bathtub
song.
Centuries after that awful experience, as
Dr. Michaud watched most of his colleagues
give up and choose the closest thing to death
in this broken world, he became even more
determined to do something about it.
On January 14, 3030, Dr. Michaud abandoned
the SCPS Naismith, and his fellow O5 council
members in search of the SCPS Concrake, an
abandoned craft to the Southeast.
It wasn't an easy journey, rowing all the
way there in a lifeboat, never knowing when
the great white beast would emerge from the
water and choose him as its next unfortunate
plaything.
He could see the SCPS Concrake, still floating
there, untouched.
But before he could row any closer, something
collided with the lifeboat from below, snapping
it in half.
Dr. Michaud's stomach dropped at the sight
of pale flesh, but it was soon replaced with
relief when he saw that the thing that had
broken his lifeboat was not, in fact, UBU.
It was an injured narwhal, behaving erratically
due to its wounds.
The culprit was almost certainly UBU.
It wasn't content to just torment humans,
but instead must have been targeting any life
form that could feel pain and fear.
In his own words, Dr. Michaud had put it:
"At least a mass extinction wouldn't have
made it that personal."
After the lifeboat broke apart, Michaud swam
to the Corncrake, exhaustion and cold straining
his muscles.
It took him two hours to reach the abandoned
cargo barge and containment site, but eventually,
he managed to climb up over the side and get
on board.
There was one very special thing about the
Corncrake, the thing that made it worth crossing
the ocean in a fragile little lifeboat to
find.
Every anomaly that made the Ganymede list,
the list of anomalies considered too dangerous
to abandon even in an apocalyptic scenario,
was contained on the Corncrake.
If there was anything left that the Foundation,
or anyone else, hadn't tried to use to defeat
UBU, it would be on that ship.
After taking a little while to recover, Dr.
Michaud embarked on an initial exploration
of the craft.
All the staff were gone, as he had expected.
Thankfully, he still had his O5 ID card, and
it still worked like a charm, unlocking all
of the automated security systems onboard.
A lot of what he found was in ruins, but some
things had survived.
He found ten Hominid Replicators from SCP-2000,
in perfect working order.
There was a cage containing the remains of
SCP-2845, The Deer, though UBU had done significant
damage to it.
SCP-319, A Curious Device, was there, contained
in a space-locked vacuum chamber.
This one was notable for its potential ability
to destroy the universe.
He found a couple of Safe-class anomalies,
such as SCP-YEZ, "Crowd Control for the Practical
Optimist," and SCP-FNA, the "Portable Warehouse."
The latter of the two was a portable door
frame to a pocket dimension.
He also stumbled across SCP-001, Last Ride
of the Day, an old Prometheus Labs prototype
of a time machine.
And possibly most importantly, he found SCP-076.
The coffin was open, but Able didn't attack
Dr. Michaud.
He wasn't consumed with murderous rage and
bloodlust, the way he always was before.
Instead, he was just sitting on the edge of
the ship, silently staring at the sea.
When he spotted Michaud, he gave him a small
wave, and did nothing else.
The centuries of a world without death, a
world without killing, without victory in
battle, had taken its toll on him.
For possibly the first time in his eternal
life, Able was depressed.
Nine days after he first inspected the Concrake,
Michaud began to formulate a plan.
He loaded all of the hominid receptors into
SCP-FNA, using a thankfully still-working
forklift.
Next, he was able to unseal the sealed portion
of SCP-001, Last Ride of the Day, and get
his hands on the details of the anomaly.
It read: "SCP-001 is capable of temporally
relocating to its relative position 15,000
years prior to activation.
This temporal displacement is divergent/paradox-irrelevant;
in other words, a separate timeline is created
as a landing point.
For example, if an occupant from timeline
x were to murder their parents in utero in
timeline y, the y iteration of the occupant
would no longer exist, but the occupant themselves,
being from x, would be unharmed.
When in a fully active state, SCP-001 deploys
a five-meter-high telescopic antenna that
functions as a Koloko wave energy sink."
Essentially, Koloko waves could only be produced
as a byproduct of the Universe suddenly being
exterminated, and ZK-class reality failures
produce the most Koloko waves.
In one of these scenarios, SCP-001 would be
able to use these waves to go back in time
15,000 years, effectively resetting reality
to a point far before that catastrophe happened.
This information allowed him to put his plan
together, to resurrect Project Beluga.
Step one, plant explosive charges around SCP-319.
Step two, hide anything potentially useful
against SCP-UBU inside of SCP-FNA.
Step three, get into the cockpit with SCP-FNA
in tow.
Step four, raise the Koloko sink.
And step five...blow the whole thing up.
Three days later, it was time to put the plan
into motion.
Dr. Michaud placed the charges around SCP-319's
vacuum chamber.
There was enough in place to implode the walls
of the vacuum chamber.
He closed the bulkhead and began deploying
the Koloko sink.
10 percent...25 percent...30 percent...
Suddenly, he could hear a loud crashing sound.
The ship began to tilt.
Oh no...
He could hear the distant sound of menacing
giggles.
The sink reached 45%, 57%, but as UBU grew
closer, he quickly overrode the system to
lower the sink.
45%, 30%, 25%, 10%.
UBU grew closer and closer, and as it approached,
it began to whistle the tune it once used
when it "bathed" Michaud and his wife in the
sewer.
UBU began to pound against the blast door,
becoming increasingly frustrated as it struggled
to break through.
Suddenly, another voice cut through the air,
an unexpected one.
SCP-076, Able, called out to Michaud, encouraging
him to carry on while Able held the beast
back.
As Able and UBU engaged in an epic battle,
Michaud suddenly remembered something: there
was an express deployment module for the Koloko
sink.
With no time to waste, he activated it.
All at once, he hit the detonator.
And then...the year was 11,970, and the date
was February 14.
13,963 years later, the SCP Foundation discovered
something beneath a mound of earth and snow
near the northern border of Lapland, Finland.
It was a shipping container with a reinforced
exterior, the interior of which could only
be accessed through a fortified bulkhead on
one side.
The words SCP-001 were written on the side
in black paint.
In spite of this, the object was given the
designation SCP-8048.
A narrow, winding tunnel through the mound
of earth and snow was discovered, leading
from the door to the outside world.
The tunnel had significant wear, clearly having
been used as a footpath by someone.
But who?
Well, on April 12, 1993, the Foundation got
their answer.
SCP-8048's bulkhead opened, and a man stepped
out, snapping his fingers and promptly sealing
the door behind him.
He was designated PoI-8048.
He was a 32-year-old man of French Canadian
descent, answering to the name of Dr. Laurence
Michaud.
He made a series of claims that the Foundation
found dubious, but noted in the official file
for SCP-8048 just the same.
These included, but were not limited to:
"SCP-8048 is a time machine.
He held the office of O5-11 in the year 3030
from an alternate timeline.
Said timeline experienced a "modified" ΩK-Class
End-of-Death scenario that coincided with
the invasion of a Tiamat-class anomaly known
as SCP-UBU.
SCP-UBU was an extremely dangerous and sadistic
entity who was capable of, among other things,
neutralizing SCP-169 and SCP-682.
His timeline's version of the Foundation launched
"Project Beluga," which resulted in an impossible
war with SCP-UBU that lasted 441 years.
PoI-8048 deliberately sabotaged SCP-319 to
act as a power source for SCP-8048, thus arriving
in Lapland in the year 11,970 BCE.
SCP-UBU will arrive in Greenland on May 12th,
2588.
PoI-8048 was able to extend his lifespan by
sharing his consciousness between a central
computer within SCP-8048 and several thousand
bodies created by his personal hominid replicators.
Said consciousness-sharing was achieved through
a book classified in the future as "SCP-YEZ."
He wishes to assist the Foundation in the
termination of SCP-UBU, and has laid out a
plan for its termination as outlined in Document-8048-Zeta."
There were, of course, concerns about the
man's legitimacy, but after Michaud mentioned
over 104 specific terms and data points known
only to members of the O5 Council, the Foundation
was forced to take him at least a little bit
seriously.
A motion was filed, requesting that PoI-8048
be allowed to assist the Foundation with the
termination of SCP-UBU as per Document-8048-Zeta.
O5-4 voted Yea, O5-7 abstained, and the rest
of the council voted Nay.
The motion failed to pass.
A follow-up motion was filed in response,
requesting that PoI-8048 be allowed to assist
the Foundation with their own strategy to
respond to SCP-UBU.
O5-1, O5-4, O5-7, and O5-10 abstained from
voting.
The rest voted Nay.
The motion failed to pass.
On April 14, 1995, Dr. Isaiah Henderson and
PoI-8048 sat down for an interview.
When asked to state his name, Dr. Michaud
also recited a memetic passphrase that, when
spoken by anyone other than an O5-11 of past
or present, would cause them to burst into
flames.
The two men were at odds from the beginning,
Dr. Michaud expressing dismay and frustration
that his proposal was rejected.
Meanwhile, Dr. Henderson countered with the
insistence that Michaud's proposed plan was
rejected for posing an unnecessary risk to
the civilian public.
They debated for a moment, before Dr. Henderson
announced the Foundation's next plan of action.
Dr. Michaud was to be terminated, and the
Foundation would proceed with its plans without
him.
At that point, Dr. Henderson terminated Michaud,
as ordered.
He didn't count on one thing, though: Michaud
was no longer an ordinary man, bound to one
body.
He hopped into the body of a guard, then into
the body of O5-4, to deliver a vital message.
He had started this plan alone, and he was
ready to bring it to a close alone.
Project Beluga would continue, with or without
the Foundation's support.
Dr. Michaud returned to the bulkhead, climbing
back inside and sealing it behind him.
He had hoped to have the Foundation behind
him, had hoped they would be allies in the
fight against the greatest evil mankind ever
encountered.
But they disappointed him.
He had waited thousands of years, only for
the organization he devoted his life to to
try and kill him.
Well, he wasn't going to go down without a
fight.
This was bigger than the Foundation, bigger
than anyone.
And no living person was as equipped to handle
UBU as he was.
So, he resumed Project Beluga, as a one-man
operation.
He issued a mission statement, which read
as follows:
"On May 12th, 2588, the entity known as SCP-UBU
invaded and pillaged human civilization for
no other motivation than cruelty and selfish
gratification.
Shortly thereafter, Project Beluga was founded
as a joint effort between the Global Occult
Coalition and the SCP Foundation for the purposes
of UBU's destruction.
UBU is not merely a threat to human safety.
He is an affront to every positive and loving
concept in the human consciousness.
Rather than our lives, he seeks to destroy
our quality of life to sate his own sick desires.
Think about it: The taste of ice cream.
Playing with your dog.
The way you felt after your first kiss.
That is UBU's sworn enemy.
No fate is too cruel for him.
No hatred is strong enough.
When Project Beluga's charter was signed,
592 GOC officers and Foundation staff were
present at the ceremony.
Our troops numbered in the hundreds of thousands.
I, Dr. Laurence Michaud, am the only surviving
member - and always will be.
What I lack in numbers is compensated thousandfold
by my weapons, my mind, my replicated bodies,
and eons of experience.
The following record serves one purpose alone:
that once justice has been brought to UBU,
humans in the shining and golden UBU-free
future will understand that one person can
accomplish through the power of hard science
and raw emotion entwined in a perfect and
indestructible braid. …and while we're at
it, you're very welcome."
Over the next several hundred years, Michaud
worked to secure ownership of Kangaatsiaq,
Greenland, through a Project Beluga civilian
front.
He evacuated the civilian population from
the area, then spent a century constructing
a superweapon.
With 100 high-yield nuclear weapons, heat-amplification
runes, a targeting beacon for SCP-DAG, and
five antimatter-gathering pods from SCP-HNM
in place, he was finally ready for UBU to
manifest again.
Now check out “The O5 Council Must Die SCP-001
- The Way It Ends - Ouroboros Cycle” and
“Insane SCP-001 Fight - Gate Guardian VS
Scarlet King!”